foreign Ronnie
Ronnie where'd you grow up where are you
from originally okay uh
I was born in New York
I was born in New York in a
it was me and my brother my father and
my mother
we lived in a Project's Queensbridge
projects
up until I was
eight my brother was nine
my brother
me my brother and some of my friends and
some of my friends we we used to
like to get a lot of mischief and
we serve
at a park called River Park right right
by on the East River
we should go and just
go all over the park but we went in a
section where we wasn't supposed to go
and my brother slipped on some wood and
he fell he fell into the East River and
he drowned
and
I had to go tell my mother you know my
brother fell in the rivers
he did he's gone you know and
they didn't find his body for maybe
maybe a week and a half
his body that got sucked into some other
like filters that the uh Con Edison the
electric company in New York that they
had and
that was just that was a that was a lot
for my for my folks so
we headed out this way to California
so
from like eight and a half
till now this is where I've been from
from California so this is really like
where I feel I'm from
how'd you describe your chocolate other
than that tragedy
well
no I'm 55 right now looking back looking
back you know
it was it would be considered a a bad
childhood
but like I say at the time
[Music]
I didn't know you know I I knew
you know I'm saying I knew he was broke
I know we didn't we didn't have no money
you know I'm saying my father drank
he was a cold alcoholic so he drank that
peppermint schnapps
and you know
and
from that the ass whoopings that he used
to give me and and all that I used to
run away a lot
I used to like to run away
to me running away was fun
because nobody could tell me what to do
I was in the streets
24 7. I always hung around older older
kids
so you know for me it was it was it was
a it was fun
even even when I was I was I started
they started
sending me to McLaren Hall
juvenile hall to me all that was fun
it was like camp
you know
and you know my poor mother she's
it was killing her because you know she
she just wanted to know where I was at
you know she wanted to know I was alive
so sometimes I'd be gone I mean I'm like
11 12 years old I might be gone like two
months
just in the streets just
stealing and just doing all that you
know
so
that's how it worked for me that's how I
got introduced to gangs
to me to me gang gang members was
like the coolest thing going like if he
wasn't a gang member then you was
missing out on something
you know
so you know
then
when I was
16
I was at that I was at my mother and
father's house
and
my father
he introduced me
to crack cocaine
he had just got a settlement he got us
some he was working for
uh Western Union I think it was
delivering uh telegrams back then when
they had telegrams you know
and some a dog had bit him up
so
he sued whatever somehow he ended up
getting seventy thousand dollars
he got that money and this is in this
was in 83 Los Angeles
that's when crack cocaine has just it
was just now hitting la
and it got my pops in and through his
thinking you know through the drugs
whatever he thought you know
kicking up with a son you know
he gave me something and when I took
that first hit
it was like the Gates of Heaven opened
up
like of like for real like like Harps
and birds and all that chirping and like
you know
and
and I that started me on on that
crack cocaine and and it had a hole on
me
for at least 30 years
you know
in and out of prison
in and out of prison just that was my
life
you know
I was
I felt more I felt more
normal
around
people that was in prison inmates living
in institutional life I felt more normal
doing in doing that than on the streets
even though I like the freedom of the
streets
I just couldn't I just couldn't conform
to no rules
couldn't nobody tell me now because
first of all I was on the drugs
you know and
and I just I was just a a the type of
person that was like
anti
anything that has to do with rules
you know
and that was my thing I just get out go
right back to the smoking
and
that's all I cared about I had already
accepted the fact that
I was gonna just die smoking smoking
crack it didn't bother me
because I felt like it's the life that I
wanted
you know
then
you know
let me let me let me let me just clarify
that
I know drugs are bad I know drugs do
[ __ ] up things the people ruin their
lives and all that I know that
and crystal meth is one of those drugs
but
to me
right now as I speak
to me
crystal meth is a wonder drug
because
crystal meth got me off crack
Crystal somebody kept telling me man
just keep smoking crystal man I'm
telling you you'll get on cracker and I
didn't believe him because I I hit her
once and I was like man what the [ __ ]
it don't do nothing
it's like who the hell gonna pay
money for this and it tastes nasty and
it just don't do nothing you know you
can't feel it
you know
and then one time I hit it and
something dawned on me
it had been like
seven eight maybe nine hours and I
hadn't even thought
a crack cocaine
and
it took me a long time to realize what
was going on
what it did was
crystal meth
took the urge
it was that urge
of chasing that rock just wanted to get
that next hit
it completely eliminated that from my
from my uh my mental
you know and
man
you know it's like
I still smoke Crystal
and like I said I know it's a drug is a
bad drug you know this and that but you
know what
I eat regularly every day I keep I keep
money I keep a few dollars in my pockets
you know
it's a few little bills I have I paid
them
you know I'm not a [ __ ] person no
more I don't lie every time everything
that I did was a I just lied just every
everything was trickery to see
you know
and
it took all that from you is you know
I'm not I know I'm not perfect right now
because I know you know I said I sell
crystal I do
you know I smoke it I do
you know uh
I buy [ __ ] stolen and I buy
food stamps from people like you know I
do I do everything just like you know
cut corners and [ __ ] but
but you know it's like
I feel to me I feel like I have a life
now I don't go to I I went to jail a
couple times this year for a little
little stuff got right up
you know what I mean but
you it used to be when I went to jail I
stayed I stayed locked up at least two
years
you know
the last little stunt the stint I did
when I went
they gave me five they gave them to know
they gave me seven seven years we have
while I was in there I caught five more
years
they caught me with some heroin
while I was in prison and
they gave me an extra five years for
that and then I finally gave me I spent
two years in the hole
I was in the shoot for two years I was
in a cell
locked down 23 out of 24 hours
two years
and I did it
and when I did that
believe it or not
I liked it
I did the whole to me was cool
because I didn't have to deal with all
that other [ __ ]
on the main line I didn't have no
selling I was by myself so I was cool
you know
and
but like I say
I haven't been smoking uh crack now
probably
four years
you know and
I've done more
in this four years
in my whole life
Little Things
going into a fast food place and having
the money to get to give what I want
seeing somewhere that I want to eat I
ain't never seen just go there and eat
you know
uh
I want people money give people money
give people drugs and stuff like that
you know what I'm saying to me to me
it's it's a step up
from what I was because I used to be
walking around walking around here
downtown like
stinking
ain't changed my clothes and the Lord
knows how long
no shower no nothing can committing
felony after felony just to keep smoking
you know
sleeping on the sidewalk and all that
you have kids
I don't have no kids no kids
I don't have no kids
you know my parents passed I have two
sisters
and we don't we don't uh we don't even
keep in contact because they really
don't even know me
when they came up I was always in jail
or
away I never
I never came around I always said I was
said I would come around for Christmas
whatever I didn't show up
you know when I was in the hole like I
said I did two years in the hole while I
was in the hole my father died while I
was in the hole you know
yeah
you know it really really I got my
family really is the few people that are
that I have out here on the streets to
me it's like more family to me than
anything
you know
and
being out here on these streets
I could say I can say yeah it's rough
it's tough but you know
when you've been out here for so long
and you know so many people that's out
here it's just what we do
it's just what's the survival thing you
know and
you you you walk around here daily
you're playing defense you're trying to
stop something from happening
something bad
because there's so many
bad things that can happen to you out
here
living this life dealing with drugs and
people that that's on drugs now people
on that Fentanyl
you know
you got to watch yourself man you can't
because you never know the person that
you talking crazy to or whatever might
just be that person
that slipped some of that fentanyl on
you
and you did because I know so many I
can't even count the people I know that
died
from fending all overdoses and
for me the majority
I know for a fact didn't use Fentanyl
you know it's the perfect
weapon for a female
perfect
weapon because you could be sleeping
there just dripping down your earlobe
down your ear your eardrum and you're
you you're just not gonna wake up
you know it can put it in your food
whatever it don't make you're just not
gonna wake up
you're gonna be dead
and
right here downtown Los Angeles
if you're dead and when the and when the
authorities show up they can tell if
it's a overdose
trust me they don't give a [ __ ]
ain't no good there's not gonna be no
investing it's gonna not gonna be
nothing you're just gonna be bagged and
tagged and
you're gonna be another John Doe
it's simple as that
I've seen it many times
you know
hey
you got to deal with down here
you got to deal with a lot of stealing a
lot of people down here are thieves
they're they're they're they're
uh Eaves of opportunity if they see
something that they could get and they
can get away with they're gonna do it
you know
and for me
it almost drove me crazy
because there was stealing from me so
much when I was living in the in the
tent
when I was in my tent
they were stealing from me so much man I
couldn't catch him I couldn't get man I
just wanted to catch someone stealing my
[ __ ] so I could make it that example
you know
and
and one day man you know what I'm saying
I caught that person
someone I know he he was he was in my
[ __ ] man
he was stealing my [ __ ]
and you know you know I'm like damn man
what the [ __ ] man what are you when I I
said look I mean what are you doing man
you in my what what's up man
he looked at me
he looked at me with old crazy look on
his face and he was like man
just chill out man man I'm gonna take
care of me I'm gonna take care of you
man you know that
and
look down here man
if someone
is taking your [ __ ] and stealing your
[ __ ] and right there in your face and
you allow it
you might as well just go on and just
every time you have something give it to
somebody because trust me it's gonna be
somebody at your door waiting to take
whatever you got
so you know hey
I wasn't about to
he I wasn't about to let nobody get away
with doing that to me man
you know
so I ain't gonna say what what I did but
trust me I handled my business
trust me I handled my business you know
what I'm saying because that's out
you know
and
he ain't dead
but you know what
he ain't got to [ __ ] my [ __ ] no more
that's what I do know
you know that's what I do know and
I didn't see him a few times after that
after that little incident and
and when he sees me
that most respect and the way he
approaches me and all that for real you
know and and I hate that it I hate that
you even have to go there like that you
know because it doesn't change anything
people are still gonna steal your [ __ ]
you know you could do whatever it you
could do so many different things to a
person
even kill him
behind stealing your stuff or whatever
and guess what
first time you leave
somebody gonna be up in your [ __ ]
stealing your [ __ ]
because like I say they they they
opportunists if they see that they get
it's actually they got actually they're
taking something and
getting away with it it's gonna happen
so it's just man it's just that you got
to just watch people man to the point
where oh man it's just
it drains you man it drains you you know
and you know like I say I've been in the
streets my whole life and even to this
day
people still get over on me
they still they still get over on me man
you know
and it's just it's just a snake that
real live snake pit
and they biting hard and they vipers man
and they coming fast
you know
uh
men women I mean hey
hey every everybody got their own
different moves and
man
what's your biggest fear now
my biggest fear
my biggest fear uh
is to be blamed for something I didn't
do
down here so you know something serious
because you know like I said I gotta my
record is long as Timbuktu and
if if I was to get arrested for you know
I'm saying like a violent Act
it's over with me man
it's over with and
and I know so many people
that's in prison as we speak
and they ain't never getting out
they ain't never getting up you know
because
hey a lot of them did whatever they in
there for
yeah but you know what a lot of them did
and I'm not just saying a few I'm saying
a lot
you know and
they don't have no hope
because
that life right there that's that's
what's that's the one for them
they just happen to be born
and be
the wrong color and the wrong situation
the wrong so many wrong things and hey
it is what it is
you know
if you had your life to live all over
again what would you have done
differently
main thing I would have done
I wouldn't have I wouldn't uh put so
much emphasis on what other people think
wanting people to like me
you know
not one uh
people people wanting people to uh think
I was cool
I wanted to be one of the cool dudes
you know and and and caring so much and
putting so much emphasis on what other
people think
uh just led me to all the wrong people
you know
of course I wouldn't use drugs
but if I could do it all over one thing
one of my biggest regrets in life really
is not graduated from high school
you know
that was one of my biggest regrets
and
I just wish I wouldn't have hurt my
mother so much
for a woman I just told her I just I
didn't know though I didn't it's not
that I was just sterile to it you know I
was like she gonna be all right she
gonna
but I you know
you know she's been
so much time just just worrying about me
just wondering what can she do to make
it make me you know into a decent person
you know
but uh
let her down all the way up to the day
she died
you know I wish I could take that back
that's that's the one that like at night
time
what I'm just just thinking it's just me
that's the one that just keeps me up at
night you know
I did my mother wrong
straight up I did
you know I let her down too many times
you know
been in love before
have I been in love before
um
I think it was love
long I was young you know
but I got a quick I got a quick lesson
in life
quick lesson in life when I went to jail
when I went to prison
I got a quick lesson in life position
that uh what you think is yours
nah
it's not always yours it's not you know
you got to listen to that to your
partner and listen to what she's saying
you know
and
and
while I was in prison she told me that
you know she told her because all she's
I told I didn't care about anything all
I want to do don't get that [ __ ] up
that's all I cared about and she's
sending me packages write me letters and
ever answer my phone calls and all that
I didn't care about none of that
just don't get that [ __ ] up so I'm on
her so tough about that until she just
one day she just told me she said [ __ ]
it man you want to know do you really
want to know
I said yeah I want to know she said yeah
I've been doing something since you've
been gone she said you don't know him
though
and man
that hit me like a Mike Tyson right
you know I couldn't believe you man
so I went through the one thing I
learned I learned with that
it's only one thing that men's a broken
heart and that's time
for some people it's only this much time
some people is that much time you know
and
just to just like I said broken heart a
broken hearted have you contemplating
murder because I wanted to kill her
I was just thinking about how can I kill
her and get away with
you know what I mean but
like I said after a while you just you
you you you're bad hella mad in the
beginning but as time goes on it wins
itself off so
I learned that man
can't trust no bro man you can't trust
no problem man cause they say oh man
they so they're some good actress
men are too but hey
for me
it's the women man
you know
they always have a plan
you know you're thinking you're just so
cool like she just wants you earlier Oh
no you're just part of her plan
you know so
right what would you say is the most
important lesson you've learned in your
life
the most important lesson I've learned
in my life
is
you you
everybody wants things they want they
want they want this whether it be money
girls cars whatever they they everybody
wants wants things you know
but one thing I've learned
is you can't you can't
get things
until you learn how to give
you got to give you can't just be so you
can't be selfish you can't and yes and
you know a lot of times your your mind
tells you
you might walk past somebody whatever in
your mind and tell you man look I can
give them they said but you don't you
just keep walking you know you got to go
with your you got to go with your first
mind if you if you think you can help
somebody else
tell somebody something or treat
somebody a certain way if if everybody
is just talking about this person
whatever and you could be that person
that just you know that just doesn't do
that
give something give
and you're gonna give
you
know
simple as that you don't you don't have
to be like everybody else
you know really you don't
you'll sleep better at night you'll feel
better as a person
you know
be yourself you know and
and just be you know just genuinely just
a
good person
all right Ronnie thank you so much for
sharing your story appreciate it very
interesting